of all the upgrades to the iPhone 7 the
most exciting is the dual lens camera
which among other things is supposed to
be much better in low light but how much
better well we tested it out by taking
pictures with the iPhone 7 plus and the
video you're watching right now with
iPhone 7 with an F 1.8 aperture image
stabilization and an even brighter flash
the iPhone 7 + + makes shooting in dim
light even easier we started at Golden
Hour that magical time just before
sunset it was a bit overcast outside but
the camera did great anyway the image
was sharp crisp and gorgeous colors but
when you switch from the wide-angle to
the 2x zoom it starts getting a little
fuzzy and noisy but only a little bit we
then hiked up to a sweeping view of San
Francisco at sunset it was still pretty
bright and I got some great views of the
city and some crisp silhouettes of other
hikers checking out the view the zoom
seems to function best with the definite
light source like this backflip shot
zoom in on the city though and it starts
getting blurry after a couple of shots
the plus did okay when it got really
dark and look natural bokeh the sky is
noisy my friend Sarah is in focus okay
so what about wandering around at night
the iPhone is killer with contrasting
scenarios featuring a definite light
source zoom in and it's still excellent
now for a cocktail shot the bar was
dimly lit with multiple light sources
coming from the TV's candles and orange
overhead lights no matter how hard we
tried it was difficult to get a crisp
shot of the cocktail without the flash
but it did seem to pick up on the
different kinds of light and the zoom
don't bother because it wasn't happening
the whole evening we shot in RAW but the
outcome wasn't really any different and
the average person probably isn't going
to bother with that anyway there are
tons of apps that enhance or help
different aspects of the iPhone camera
but we wanted to see what the new lenses
did on their own without a bunch of
editing conclusion the iPhone 7 plus
can't compete with a DSLR app will never
claim that though it is a step up from
the iPhone 6 but the camera isn't the
only reason I'd upgrade